hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his work on
fate Cicero is concerned with the
problem of human freedom and fate and
determinism and causality and how all
these things come together he examines a
range of positions in this work and
endorses some and critically attacks
others one of the extreme positions that
he sets out and it's unfortunate that it
doesn't actually go into greater detail
about this because we don't have works
by him is that of the logician and the
head of the Megerian school d odorous
who came up with a line of argumentation
or an account called para do newton
which means something about about
possibility and it really rules out
possibility in the way that we think of
in our ordinary dealings with the world
and our understanding of our own choices
d odorous staked out what we can look at
as a extreme and perhaps entirely
consistent position that in effect says
that
everything everything that you can
possibly think of not only in the past
not only in the present but even for
everything in the future happens of
necessity you can also say that the
things that do happen are possible but
nothing else is possible from his point
of view so this is very different than
most other philosophical approaches to
these fundamental whatever you want to
call them categories modalities of
possibility necessity and impossibility
before we look at the examples that get
brought up in relation to the odorous
let's talk about what Cicero tells us do
Doris's position was on each of these
things so possibility is actually fairly
straightforward although rather
counterintuitive or paradoxical
according to D odorous only what is true
or what is going to be true what will be
true is possible and you could say what
do you mean by true well you could talk
about statements what is you know going
to be the case we can represent that
linguistically or mentally by
visualizing it or understanding it and
we can say that propositions are true or
false so I am going to walk across the
room true proposition I'm going to walk
across the room again true proposition I
will now walk across the room again
turns out to be false right and the
odorous would say only the things that
happened in the past that we can talk
about that or think about or are
happening right now or will be happening
in the future only those are possible
now with the past that's a bit
counterintuitive because you might think
about
it's the tie that I'm wearing right now
I could have picked a different time I
could have chosen not to wear a tie and
all we would say that the odorous would
say no that was not a possibility what
happened that's the only thing that's
actually possible the future is even
more of a stretch I think for many of us
because we tend to think of the future
as not yet determined the odorous would
say only what is actually going to
happen is even possible none of the
other range of what we call
possibilities are genuine possibilities
let's talk now about necessity so when
we say that something is necessary we
mean that it has to happen if we're
talking about occurrence or existence or
if we're talking about it existing in a
certain way and we say that it exists in
that way of necessity it must exist in
that way and we often assume a certain
kind of necessity between the relations
of causes and effects the odorous tells
us as far as necessity goes that
whatever will be must necessarily happen
so it's not just that only what is going
to happen is possible not only is it
possible it's necessary and again this
is rather counterintuitive because we
often do in fact think of many things as
existing in a whole range of different
possibilities none of which are actually
necessary they are contingent upon
something like my decision the odorous
would say no even your decision that is
already something decided ahead of time
so only he says whatever will be must
necessarily happen then he tells us
nothing happens that was not necessary
and really these are two different ways
of looking at the same thing but the
tense is important here nothing happens
nothing occur
in the present or in the future or if
we're thinking about what happened in
the past that was not necessary that
didn't already have a kind of necessity
producing it causing it guiding it
making it be what it what it is going to
be what it was in the past what it will
be in the future what it is in the
present so now we have necessity and
possibility and it's restricted to the
range of what is what has been and what
will be all other what will be is have
been excluded
Cicero tells us a little bit more about
the odorous on impossibility and this is
I think the most interesting part and
where it becomes most stark he tells us
that whatever will not be cannot
possibly happen so this is another way
of you might say it's the flip side of
the coin of possibility it's another way
of talking about what it is to be
possible whatever will not be so my not
choosing a different tie could not
possibly happen it's impossible that I
wore a different tie to create this
lecture for you it's impossible that you
didn't watch this lecture now you may
say I could have chosen differently nope
you could not have chosen differently
there actually was no choice there or if
we want to interpret it as there being a
choice somehow it was a choice that only
had one option if that makes any sense
to you let's look at the next one every
false statement about the future is an
impossibility what is a false statement
about the future well some of them are
by their very nature or the nature of
things going to be false a Bachelor will
no longer be an unmarried male but
rather be a married male next we
okay there we're talking about something
that's an impossibility because we're
talking about the way that we use
language right that's often viewed as an
analytic statement a bachelor's a an
unmarried male but we could also say
things like I will be alive 500 years
from now that's unless there's some
massive new life extension thing that's
you know false and it's an impossibility
that the state of affairs that that
statement names could in fact be the
case now we might say that that
statements like I will be alive or I
will be dead next week
those are both possibilities but the
odorous would say no one of those is a
possibility and the other one is an
impossibility already because the future
already is the way it is either true or
false the statements about it are the
way that they they are so either I am
alive in the future in which case the
statement I will be alive a week from
now is a true statement and it's
possible for me to be life in the future
or if I'm dead in the future a week from
now then the statement I will be alive a
week from now not only is false it is an
impossibility
I cannot possibly be alive a week from
now because in some way it's already
decided the last thing that he says
about impossibility is that it's no more
possible for things that will be to
alter than it is for things that have
happened to alter that's a really
critical idea here the odorous thinks
you know we could we could frame it this
way because we don't actually have his
own words
Theodorus thinks the future is written
in stone so to speak if we want to use
that metaphor he thinks that everything
that will be in the future has already
been decided
in some way now he doesn't go into any
great detail neither his sister on his
reconstruction about precisely how that
happens but we can imagine in this this
book on fate that Doris probably had
some sort of conception of causal agency
working here and some sort of massive
concatenation of interlinking causes
that runs all the way from the past as
far as the most distant origin or
whatever of the past through our present
and forward into the future all of it
determined none of it having any scope
not only for human freedom but even for
possibility in the sense that we
normally ascribe to things that we think
could have been the case but didn't turn
out to be that way or it could be the
case but won't turn out to be that way
instead it is a doctrine that postulates
what we might call a pure and
across-the-board completely consistent
necessity
you